this is actually a my little pony would
drink their bits in here that I want to
get out what does this is this coconut
yeah that's like creamy and it's icy
it's got this like rosy Island feel to
it
oh my god
this is very like typical Asian fare of
just eating an entire fish I've never
had fish stuff with a head I don't mind
that the fish is served whole in fact I
actually prefer it all the flavors have
seeped into it was probably cooked over
some kind of like open fire it tastes
like it just came sure to have a BBQ
this is awesome that's delicious
it's like a peanut sauce salad some eggs
it's good to have some protein with your
salad mmm boom crack oh there's other
things underneath there such a bitter
egg cracker I just kind of stopped were
you okay
whoa Indonesian flute is blowing my mind
an evening with rice and fried myths I
get so excited about this fried rice
tastes a little sweeter than the fried
rice I'd normally eat kind of shrimpy
smells like fish sauce maybe it's not
too oily or greasy super flavorful yeah
noodle this looks like chow mein at
least to my new favorite food type
Indonesian what is the history of
Indonesia that all these foods are so
blended it's not greasy I love it when
the egg is like darker brown from all
the sauce like really like marinated
into it you know it's gonna be like
super flavorful and good oh my god
befriending be farmed in a meat pile has
appeared in front of me I looked at it
and I was kind of skeptical and nervous
but it tastes amazing coconut and meat
and like chili there's lots of spices
and herbs in here I feel like it needs
some of those pong crackers or something
to just really get in there and just get
every little nook and cranny this would
be delicious over rice why have I never
had this food before how have I lived so
long and never had this food I was super
impressed at the diversity of flavor it
was really delicious it was just so
surprising it's very rustic it's very
flavorful it's like everything I like
from international cuisines put into one
Wow